[Music]
okay i have a
crazier story about this man who
survived
a crazy ass trip so he was a stowaway
he survived an 11 hour flight clinging
on
to a british airways oh i saw this from
the outside
what from africa to london south africa
it was like yeah yeah clinging from joe
and like tom cruise style
like where the wheels are more like
raffles oh okay so he was
he's in the wheel well he's in something
like that yeah he had he's clenching
there's no way but he uh he he got into
a coma or something right it'd be so
cold up there
yeah it was negative 76. negative how
was he
so he survived or what sometimes people
crawl into these rear
um this the landing gear area and
there's like a little area in there
where you can actually like
like hang out but then is that where
they put the pets and [ __ ] like in that
no no no no it's cargo still this is
like just like little little places that
the airplane tucks into it so he's a
stowaway like almost like getting on a
train but it's like super extreme
temperatures and [ __ ]
so apparently there have been 109
recorded stowaway attempts around the
world
wow london being one of the most popular
destinations but only 24 people who took
their chances
in a air a plane's landing gear have
survived
oh my god first known survivor
was this 12 year old who hit on a flight
from indonesia to australia back in 1946
oh wow he probably just held onto his
boner to keep himself warm huh
and then only two he could keep it hard
for a while yeah yeah there have only
been two people who have lived after
stowing
stowing away to britain which was this
car mechanic from punjab who endeared
endured a 10-hour flight from delhi to
london in 1996
and the second person was this guy that
we're talking about now
so people do anything to get away what
did he do
what huh nothing nothing i didn't hear
you no this guy's like i want the
[ __ ] deal man
damn deal that's more like it yeah yeah
what if it's not even for like
immigration i'm in the plane
he just wants a vacation he's like i'm
tired of this [ __ ] and then he goes in
and then he's like i'm gonna have fun i
never seen big ben i want to do all that
[ __ ]
i want to see the harry potter train
station it was pretty awesome it would
be cool if it was that lighthearted but
no this man
he was living a rough life and so he oh
i gotta kill the joke
well i had to give you the facts so he
was actually
like he knew it was a very dangerous
trip but he actually didn't do this trip
alone he did it with a friend of his
and a chicken who unfortunately didn't
make like he didn't survive froze like
damn
like jack at the end of titanic he had
to like
let go of his of like no so they
actually
almost made it and the last thing that
he remembers was his friend
saying like yeah we did it but
it was wrong so it is like the titanic
did it you're dead it's like hypothermia
uh no okay so i'll get to that but what
ended up happening is
that this guy named simba the guy that
survived
he went into a coma and so when he woke
up he
it was six months later and he found out
that his friend had died and he
he was so close to the end his friend
look this is where the body was found in
like on on the roof of a building so it
fell oh god
oh because the landing gear oh my gosh
it was really close to the airport so he
almost made it oh my god
so what about his buddy did they both
because i'm just imagining the like
wheel goes out like that and then since
they were both sleepy or the other guy
was dead
it just they just fall off on top of a
roof or something it's like
he had actually like i don't know about
his friend and i'm assuming he didn't
but at least this guy that survived
he did wrap an electrical cable around
around his arm so he tied himself the
guy that survived
tied himself yeah that's some [ __ ] bart
would do bart always does [ __ ]
and he never catches me up and then i
end up with the [ __ ] [ __ ] end of the
stick and i look at why he's like oh you
didn't know how to do this i'm like no
[ __ ] i wasn't a boy scout so i
get it
bart does that to me all the time you
would have ended up on the roof exactly
what did it mean you just it's common
sense okay
and tiger should know common sense too
right no he's with me okay
he's like tying himself up and then they
fall
and they're like whoa jio's going why
didn't you why did you do that
but yeah so the reason like you guys
were asking how did he survive the
freezing temperatures and they're saying
that
those temperatures it it kept them in a
suspended animation so it says with a
lowered core body temperature
the heart brain and other critical
organs are placed into
a standby mode which they do not require
nearly as much oxygen thus limiting
damage to cells like lizards
yes so that's kind of like people who
fell asleep
in the car and then they get into like a
car accident and then they're the only
ones that survive
yeah because they're all relaxed yeah
like jellyfish that's why kids end up
surviving a lot of crazy [ __ ] too
because
they're not as like tense but anyway so
then
uh he was saying that when they when
the plane was arriving that when the
wheels came out
he did fall so he ended up having a
shattered leg
and he burned his arm pretty badly too
to the point where he needed surgery
um and so he just remembers like
like waking up and then seeing his
shattered leg and then seeing like guard
people come and get him and he passed
out he didn't wake up until six months
later at that point you're paying
way more for the surgery than you would
have for a plane ticket
well no well for him it was like life or
death to leave the country
it wasn't a vacation nicki yeah he was
trying to like
survive yeah yeah so he fell from the
the landing gear area to the to the
ground after they landed
[ __ ] yeah i thought that he fell through
a roof and some british
family was having tea and crumpets and
they're like oh dear heavens
it's raining africans
[Music]
i could see that it was actually his
friend who did end up landing on a roof
but he did not make it
it was like a 5 000 drop or something
[ __ ]
he didn't make it damn that sucks
i know it's pretty crazy so here's so
the moral of the story is don't watch
action movies because he was inspired by
an action movie no
he actually they they did some research
so when he met this guy
he met him at a bar or something and
then the guy he had an estranged wife
and daughter
and he was just like [ __ ] it like i
don't know to do my life like i can't
stay here anymore and then this dude was
homeless and so was the other guy so he
was like you're just like me we're gonna
stick together
and then they started looking at
different ways of getting out of the
country
and so that's when they got like an
aviation book and they looked at
the possibility of stowing away on the
plane so they
they came up with a plan and in 2015
that's when they got on the flight
like they jumped over some gate they
almost got caught by
some guards but luckily they didn't and
yeah he ended up coming so now he still
uses crutches
till his day because something like his
leg is still messed up from it he's
hoping that they can fix it so he gets
to stay there they don't send him back
he he actually applied for asylum and he
got approved
oh that's cool who's that guy next to
him so they're doing
uh they're doing like a documentary
thing on him
um and so that guy's that's crazy dang
man
that's crazy this makes me want to talk
to my dad more because i know he did
come here
either he went to hong kong illegally or
here illegally but
it was on a boat and i know it was like
some stowaway action too
i thought he swam to hong kong he did
but then from
from hong kong to here did he go in a
car was he one of those guys
that ran out of a cargo i don't know he
could he could be so like
but like he never should know but he
never he never really talks about it
maybe it was traumatic so i think i need
to ask him before he
passes away i'd be sick yeah he's
swaying from where to hong kong
china and then his friend got shot from
a communist guard holy [ __ ]
he was he was 15. he had uh like seven
of his friends when it was him and his
girlfriend
one guy got bit by a snake going through
the mountains another guy got shot by
the guard and then they had to do it
like three times for them to make it was
like oregon trail in real life yeah
you see i'm weird and then sometimes we
get scared we're going to vegas we're
like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] scary
watch out you don't want to freaking
slip and die yeah man your dad's a g
yeah that's probably why i think i'm a
[ __ ] all the time for sure 100 that's
why he laughs at everything
he's like i had to eat my own cat [ __ ]
while he's crying inside because he
doesn't know how to deal with his
emotions
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you guys are [ __ ]
give me more alcohol does this guy know
what he wants to do
like in the uk well now he's married and
he has a couple kids
um it was like more than five years ago
or
yeah maybe he works at foot locker there
or something
why foot locker i don't know why not the
jocker why wouldn't he work what could
you oh i don't know because i cuz like
something with his legs
like i know your guys's jokes are next
level so i was just trying to see how
next level they got
that wasn't even a joke that was in the
world that was just the job they have
foot lockers out there yeah
do they they're still called for or what
what would be more appropriate would be
a pret
out manager i think that's how you say
it predamenters
lost people just call it print but it's
like bakery and coffee
and stuff you're making up words no it's
it's a french company that's popular
in the englands it's called the preda
managers
i call it manager because it looks like
managers called alien vs predators
does he like this food out there because
i i didn't like the food i didn't like
idiots well does he have a choice
except for okay i heard there's good
jamaican food over there
i wonder if he's at an airport and he
just sees like airplane tires and just
yeah this is what he said he says now
i'm waiting i'm waiting to get a
passport it takes five years to get a
british passport and then i'll be able
to fly on a plane
i will be a scouser then a scouser it
sounds
bad just make it worse no no but they're
saying that
he was joking when he was saying this so
i don't get the joke it sounds like your
trousers are scary yeah you know what's
crazy is like a lot of people we know
they have stories like this like our
friends parents or whatever
my parents they're [ __ ] bougie dude
they came over here on an airplane they
don't even know what stressing is about
but like other people though i hear some
[ __ ] my stepdad was a stalway
um he he came to america that way but it
was much easier to get citizens back
citizenship back then because he ended
up working for uh
dc like he he worked in the government
but he got he came out here in his teens
or early 20s
and he did it like the boat way like
on a cargo boat and then it's like
people will just find you and they'll be
like all right [ __ ] you you're here
yeah this dude he's also saying that
like he he has like survivors guilt
because he thinks about his friend a lot
i'm sure man you know i made it he
didn't and he also
his friend didn't tie himself to it well
i don't know that well you didn't he
he didn't tell him he was like you boys
he's like you didn't know what the [ __ ]
man
common sense but yeah so he was saying
like he didn't even get to go to his
funeral because he was in a coma
during his funeral and yeah he feels
really good can you imagine waking up to
this world
like imagine if he did this pre-kovid
right and then he woke up
and it's just like hella covered style
that's some walking dead [ __ ]
yeah true but you're asking me what he
does now and
i said he was married but that was
actually the other survivor this guy
he now lives in a one bedroom flat in
liverpool and
isn't unable to work due to his injury
oh
bombers trying to figure he doesn't have
to work or be married wow
so maybe he did get the dream well at
least he's not
like needing to survive crazy crazily
like in his old place because he said he
said i had to leave africa to survive
i would give other people advice it's
not safe it's a life or death situation
look that's not good for him i'm glad
he's alive yeah
good thing he made it
[Music]
you